skills stack exponentially let's say  you're a videographer you got a video  skill now you got an editing skill now  you understand social media messaging  copywriting and branding  management and operations and leadership  see how that person starts to expand you  can imagine how their pay is going to  dramatically increase because now you're  a cmo the amount of like copywriting  courses and books and programs  mentorships and even one-on-one coaching  to learn a new skill if you're like i  need to know how to run an ad go pay  someone who runs ads or teaches people  how to run ads broadening your horizon  and going deep in these other silos then  all of a sudden you're an entrepreneur